because Jessica I know you are a fan of
the British television oh my goodness
someone told you yes I was here this
spring shooting a movie the Huntsman and
I stumbled across a show called
embarrassing bodies the episode I saw is
all about penises and they were four
stops of penises that had problems I
couldn't believe these people actually
decided to go on the show yep and
showcase their embarrassing can I show
you something I'm really embarrassed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm wondering what some of the nevermind
oh yes yes I have and yeah you're right
I mean it's extraordinary that what
people think I'm sorry I'm mortified by
this I better go and reveal myself on
television that way somehow it's
expunged this embarrassment but it is
it's extraordinaire it's a very British
thing I think it is where we have we
have been very embarrassed about bodies
so we but we'd like to tell people about
things I couldn't even have imagined
tentacles or tails are they just like
things that didn't even look like part
of the human body yeah well you're so
sheltered
I literally looked at it I was alone
with it and I said to myself thank God I
didn't [__] anybody over for this and I
suddenly had this and I would use your
ponytail to steer while you dine upon my
lady sound
[Applause]
she's really thought it through